we've had paid guests for our podcast
I'm like hey you want to be on the
podcast fill out a form right today
there's so many successful people in the
world like being successful it's not
like Gonna Get You On a show what's
gonna get you on the show the only way
you could add value to me is number one
you have an audience already that's
great you come on the show it's a
win-win but then the other way just be
financially if you're gonna help us pay
for all these costs we incur cool for
anybody who thinks that's a weird vibe
or something well if you really simplify
it you're talking about like investing
marketing dollars do you spend it on
Facebook ads do you buy a billboard do
you buy a TV commercial a podcast could
be a commercial people make the mistake
and they'll be like oh well let me go
get garyvee to be on my show dude you're
gonna go pay like 50 G's at least like
you're not gonna get a return on that
but if you could get on garyvee show
that would be a game changer